you've gone to a fruit stand to get some
fresh produce you notice that the person
in front of you gets five apples and
four oranges for ten dollars
you get five apples and five oranges for
eleven dollars
can we solve for the price of an apple
at an orange using this information in a
system of linear equations and two
variables if yes what is the solution if
no what is the reason we cannot so we're
trying to figure out the price of an
apple and the price of an orange so i
would use a for apple but i don't like
using o for orange because o looks too
much like a zero so i'll just say
x for apples
let's let x equals
let's let x
equal the price of apples
price of
apples
and let's let y
let's let y equal the price of oranges
price of oranges
so let's describe what happened to the
person in line in front of us they
bought five apples so how much did they
spend on apples well they but they
bought five apples times x dollars per
apple so they spent five x dollars on
their five apples and they bought four
oranges so they spent four
they bought four oranges times y dollars
per orange so they spent 4y on oranges
so the total amount that they spent is
5x plus 4y
and they tell us that this is 10. this
is equal to 10.
now you get in line and you buy five
apples
so you buy five apples just like the guy
in front of you and you paid x dollars
per apple so you're gonna pay five time
five apples times the price per apple
this is the amount that you spend on
apples and then you buy five oranges
you buy five oranges so you're going to
pay five oranges times the price per
orange which is y so this is how much
you spend on oranges this is how much
you spent on apples and oranges this sum
and they tell us that this is going to
be this is 11 dollars can so so can we
solve for an x and a y
and it looks like we can and a big
giveaway right over here is the ratio
between the x's and the y's and these
two equations are different so we're
getting some information here if the
ratios were exactly the same if this was
5x plus 4y right over here and we got a
different number then we would be in
trouble because we bought the same
combination but we got a different price
but the good thing is is that we have a
different combination here
so let's see if we can work it out now
the most obvious thing that jumps out at
me is that i have a 5x here and i have a
5x right over here so if i could
subtract this 5x from that 5x then i
would cancel out all of the x terms so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
multiply this bottom equation by
negative 1 so it becomes negative 5x
minus 5 or plus negative 5y is equal to
negative 11.
and then i'm going to essentially add
both of these equations and i can do
that because i'm doing the same thing to
both sides i already know that this
thing is equal to this thing so i'm just
adding those things to either side so on
the left hand side
on the left hand side
i have 5x minus 5x well those cancel out
and then i have and then i have 4y minus
5y well that's negative y and that's
going to be equal to
10 minus 11 which is negative 1.
and then if we multiply both sides of
this times negative 1 or divide both
sides by negative 1 we're going to get y
is equal to 1. so just like that we were
able to figure out the price of oranges
it's one dollar per orange now let's
figure out so this is equal to one now
let's figure out the price of apples so
we can go back into either one of these
equations i'll go back into this first
one
so five times so let's go to the person
in line in front of us they bought five
apples at x dollars per apple
plus four oranges
at one dollar per orange
and they spent a total of ten dollars
they spent a total of ten dollars
so this of course is just four let's
subtract four from both sides
and we get
we get well four times one minus four
that just cancels out we're just going
to be left with five x on the left hand
side
we're just going to have 5x on the
left-hand side and on the right-hand
side we have 10 minus 4 which is equal
to 6 and we can just divide both sides
by 6 now in order to solve for x
and so
we
get oh sorry we can divide both sides by
5 in order to solve for x
my brain is it's late in the day brain
isn't working so dividing by 6 wouldn't
have done anything we would have gotten
5 6x we just want to get an x here so
dividing both sides by 5
we get x is equal to six-fifths dollars
or you could say that x
x is equal to six-fifths which is the
same thing as one and one-fifth which is
the same thing as one dollar twenty so
it's a dollar per it's a dollar per
orange and a dollar 20 per apple so we
absolutely could figure out the prices
of apples and oranges using the
information given